- What I would like to do
is I'm gonna talk for
about hopefully 30 minutes,
'cause I do want this to
be more of a discussion,
and have question and answer.
What I would like to do
is I will be speaking somewhat formally,
somewhat informally.
I'll try to show some images
and then leave plenty of time at the end
for questions and answers.
So, what I'd like to do in some ways
is to lay out my two main arguments
that I would like to
make in this talk today.
And then I'm gonna provide
three case studies,
one in Guam, one in Malaysia,
and one in Hong Kong.
First of all Erik, I really
appreciate your introduction,
and in many ways it makes me feel
like I succeeded on some level,
'cause my goal was to tell
the story of the refugee camps
and what is the actual
politics of the place
that hosted the refugee camps.
As many of you know
there's a lot of literature
on Vietnamese American
studies, more broadly.
In my work I chose not to focus
on the politics of Vietnam
or why people left,
nor do I really look
at resettlement issues,
whether it's the United
States, Australia, Canada,
or in Europe.
Instead, what I'm interested in
how did the politics of place matter,
in these various places
that hosted the camps.
I would argue that we learn a great deal
about the specificity
of who gets to be a
refugee and who doesn't,
based on the regional
dynamics of that place.
It made a great deal of difference
if you were in the Philippines,
versus if you were in Malaysia,
or if you were in Hong Kong.
How did it matter, for example,
if we're thinking about Malaysia,
the politics of Mahathir, or
Malaysian racial politics,
versus politics of the Marcos era,
in the Philippines in the 1980s.
One of my key arguments is that,
the dynamics of the local place mattered,
the refugee status was just not
a matter of what the UN said
or what the United States said,
but mattered a lot about the
local politics of the places
that hosted the camps.
That's argument one.
I'll just say briefly,
I'm not discussing the
Philippines in this talk,
I'm very happy to talk about
the Philippines as well,
and I'm really interested that.
If I don't talk about the Philippines
and your interest in the
Philippines, please ask questions.
Secondly, I'm also interested
in Asian American studies
and in critical refugee studies.
I would like this talk to
be of interest and value
to people who are just in
Southeast Asian history,
but also to scholars of
Asian American studies
and those intersections
with refugee studies.
In my book, I hope that
I show multiplicity,
agency, and complexity of
the Vietnamese men and women
I write about.
Very simply, and this I
think should be obvious,
the individuals I write
about were far from passive,
they were not object.
They were in fact political actors.
I think I managed to write the book
without ever saying, "the
plight of the refugee".
Rather I'm much more interested
in the decisions people were making,
how they negotiated,
how they understood their
time within the camps,
whether or not they
wanted to then resettle
in the United States,
or another settlement country,
or even if they wanted
to go back to Vietnam.
My story in many ways,
I think complicates an image
of Vietnamese refugees,
which I think is still focused
much disproportionately
on the 1975 migration,
and the individuals who
resettled after 1975,
well often not recognizing
the hundreds of thousands
who left after 1975
in the late 70S, the 80S,
and even through the 1990s.
By showing those variations
by thinking about Chinese Vietnamese,
by thinking about people who
left from Northern Vietnam,
or Central Vietnam
in relationship to those
coming from Southern Vietnam,
I'm hoping to show a much
more complicated story,
which I also connect
with diasporic activism
among Vietnamese who resettled
both in the United States,
as well as in Australia.
So I look at the intersections
of Vietnamese in the camps
and diasporic actors
disproportionately in the United States,
but to some extent in Australia as well.
So those are the two main arguments.
What I would like to do
is begin by bringing us to
where I started this project,
which was with this image.
I found this image when I
was doing archival research,
actually about a different project
related to refugee camps
in the United States,
and this is an image of
Vietnamese in Guam, in 1975.
It is a group of Vietnamese,
as probably most of you
in this Zoom Room know,
approximately 100,000 Vietnamese leave
at the end of the US war.
The majority of these men and women
come to the United
States, Canada or France.
What I did not know
was that most of them go to Guam first.
In some ways, if you
think about it makes sense
that you don't just show
up from a boat in Saigon
to California,
but the United States brought
most of these individuals
to Guam for screening.
Most of these individuals did in fact
want to come to the United
States or a resettlement country.
But some did not,
about 2000 did not.
I found this image and I was just like,
"What is going on?
"Who are these men who
want go back to Vietnam?"
"How are they protesting with this image
"of Ho Chi Minh in the background?"
'Cause what I had learned and
served as general common sense
is that the majority Vietnamese Americans
in the United States,
have identified with anti-communism,
there debates over images
and serve the representations
of Ho Chi Minh,
so I was really struck by this image
and wanted to know what was going on.
Initially I thought I'd find no documents
and that was totally wrong.
There's tons of documents about this.
This in many ways came
to my research questions.
In this image
we had men who wanted
to go back to Vietnam
and did not wanna resettle
in the United States.
Just quickly to locate where we are,
Guam is right here,
it's in the Pacific.
It's actually not part of Southeast Asia,
it's part of the Pacific islands,
it is quite far from Southeast Asia.
But the United States brought Vietnamese
from Southern Vietnam to Guam for staging.
This is largely because Guam
is a US colony or territory.
It is 4,000 miles from Hawaii,
is almost 6,000 miles from California.
It became the primary staging ground
for this 1975 generation of Vietnamese
who were trying to leave the country
in the fall of South Vietnam,
and resettle in the United States.
The United States is able
to bring 100,000 people
to Guam because they do
not have to ask permission.
Guam again, as basically a US colony,
the United States has
multiple military bases
and the Guam government
simply could not say no.
And so Guam agrees to
accept all of these people,
and they were on these sort
of makeshift refugee camps
within Guam.
What I learned
is that most people (indistinct)
go to the United States.
But about 2000 choose instead
that they made a mistake.
That they did not in fact want to move on.
So here's an image from...
These are all from the
"Pacific Daily News,"
which is the Guam newspaper in English.
That you should know that
these do not represent
a tomorrow perspective.
This is really sort of an
American focus newspaper.
But why did people want to go back?
Who were these 2000 who
wanted to return to Vietnam?
I would suggest to you
that most of them...
I'm gonna stop sharing
so I can see a few of those faces.
Most of them were young men.
The assumption is that they'd
all want come to America,
but many of these were young men,
about 80% of them were young men
who had been in the South Vietnamese Navy.
But had been only 18, 19 years old,
and many of them were
like on a ship at sea.
They were in the Navy.
So one day Saigon falls and
the captain of the ship says,
"We're not going back to port.
"We're all gonna go to Guam."
And so these young men
found themselves on Guam
and were confused.
They wanted to go home.
They had no interest in going America,
at least not without their families.
Others were older,
some had been separated
from their families,
and so we're unable to sort of...
didn't wanna continue on their own.
Others were elderly people
who decided that in fact,
they didn't wanna take their
chances in the United States.
Some of their stories are very striking,
and I've written about
this in some detail.
The most traumatic is a group of officers
who flew airplanes out
of Saigon to Thailand
and could not go back to Vietnam,
unbeknownst to them.
The US actually, there's
good documentation
that they were drugged,
and put onto airplanes
and brought to Guam.
These men felt as if they were kidnapped.
That they did not mean to flee.
And so on Guam these...
And it is disproportionately men.
Most of the people protesting were men,
there were some women
but much smaller numbers.
They wanna go back to Vietnam,
and so they begin protesting.
These protests begin to escalate.
The United States
honestly doesn't know
what to do with them.
They don't wanna force them
to come to the United States,
they also don't really
know how to bring them back
to Vietnam,
and the Guamanian
government wants them off.
The Guamanian government is like,
"We don't need this headache.
"Who are these people?
"You said this was going to be brief,
"and now people are burning down buildings
"and marching up and down."
I just wanna show you
some of these images.
I was not actually able to
include these in the book,
'cause they're from the
"Pacific Daily News"
their rights were too complicated.
But the images are remarkable.
Here's one of the individuals
who left the airplane,
he did not wanna come.
You begin to see images
of people protesting
with English language signs,
you can see they're familiar with English.
Many of them had worked
with the US Military.
You get images like this one,
where the repatriates
walk out and protest,
hunger strikes.
"Hunger strike until die".
They burned down buildings on the bases.
Eventually the US government gives in,
for lack of a better word,
and says, "Fine, you
can go back to Vietnam,
"and we're gonna give you
your own ship to return on."
They give them this commercial vessel,
the Thuong Tin (indistinct),
and they tell these young
men, the repatriates,
that they can return.
Here's an image that really stood with me,
of them sort of celebrating this return.
In this image I think you
can really see the youth
of these men.
They were really quite young.
You can see, I think in this
image their sense of joy
that they are going home.
The goal is that they
will return to Vietnam.
They do return,
this is on October of 1975.
Here again is an image of the ship.
I had the great honor of
working with Tran Dinh Tru,
and my colleague Bac Hoai Tran,
to translate a Vietnamese memoir
about the ship that returned to Vietnam.
In some ways quite tragically,
and I think this might
surprise anyone in this room.
The Vietnamese government
was not sympathetic
towards this group of repatriates.
They saw them as potential
CIA agents, as suspect,
as potential infiltrators,
did not take them at their word,
and they were brought
to re-education camps,
when they returned in 1975.
In particular,
the author I worked with Tran Dinh Tru,
was in prison for 12 years.
Very traumatic experiences.
But why do I find the story so compelling,
and how did it bring me on
this journey through the book?
First of all,
I think it's important that
we begin the story in Guam.
Do you think Guam's politics matter?
Matters that it was a colony.
Matters that Guam could not
say no to the United States.
It mattered that Guam had this
network of US Military bases
because of the history
of US militarism on Guam.
It's also important to recognize
that the Guamanian politicians
did try to do their best
to manage the situation.
They felt responsible to
both Guamanians, Chamorros,
as well as American Military personnel.
They were trying to come
up with a way to navigate
both the pressures they had on
them from the US government,
and the pressures that they had
from these Vietnamese repatriates.
Secondly, I think it shows a
very dynamic story of activism
in one and an unexpected place.
Here we see a group of
Vietnamese who are mobilized,
who recognize their
ability to create pressure
on the US government, and
on the Guamanian government,
and seek to in fact,
direct to their own goals,
which in their case was not
coming to the United States,
but rather was returning to Vietnam.
Thirdly, I think it's a
really complicated story
'cause there's a part of me
that wants to in many ways
celebrate their activism,
celebrate their sort of political acumen,
and yet their stories, one which
is tragic in multiple ways.
Because when they return,
they are imprisoned, and
they're seen as suspect.
Many then do come to the United States
in the late '70s and early '80s,
or through the ODP, or
because they leave later.
But it is not a story
where they triumphed.
In many ways it is a much
more ambivalent story,
and one that I think demonstrates
that they did not know
what was gonna happen.
I think in many ways,
I think of Tran Dinh Tru,
he talked about leaving
Northern Vietnam in 1954
and never seeing his family
again in North Vietnam.
That was his experience
when he moved South.
When he thought, when he
was separated from his wife,
that he would never see her again.
That was a real feeling,
and it was legitimate.
And that he did not
realize when he returned,
quite how long he would be in prison,
or the trauma that that
would inflict upon him
or his family.
He does come to the
United States in the '90s
and I had the good fortune of meeting him.
That is where the story begins.
The key points are one,
the politics of Guam,
and second, the questions of activism
and third, the complexities.
So with that,
I wanna turn to my next case,
which is that of Malaysia.
Malaysia I'm gonna show you the map again,
here we go.
If we come here and we go to Malaysia,
and I also see my
colleague Quan Tran here,
I know you've done a great
deal of really fantastic work
on Malaysia.
I hope we can talk afterwards as well.
But for those of you less familiar,
maybe with the geography,
here we have Malaysia.
Malaysia is two parts,
Peninsular Malaysia,
and Eastern Malaysia.
We have Sabah here it's
partially important
I'm gonna start with the Filipino
refugees coming into Sabah
as well at the same time.
So we have a large number of Vietnamese.
This is the era which in
the West from Americans,
and in English language newspapers
often will start referring
to the "Boat people."
This gonna be a large numbers
of Vietnamese leaving.
This is after some of
the re-education camps,
really some people in the late '70s,
you also have the Vietnamese government,
having more collectivization,
sending people to new economic zones.
This leads people to leave Vietnam.
As you're gonna here,
see yourself, Vietnam,
people either went to
Thailand or to Malaysia.
You can see here the geography
was the closest proximity.
At this moment,
the largest group in Malaysia
people go to this Island
in Pulau Bidong which is in Terengganu,
which is a couple of hours
away from Kuala Lumpur.
In some ways in a sort of regional,
the Northeastern region of Malaysia.
What I would say in this case,
which I find quite interesting
is again, thinking about
the Malaysian politics
and how this fits into our story.
So in the United States,
US politicians saw all
Vietnamese as anti-communists,
as "deserving."
There's this clearly
anti-refugee sentiment
in the United States,
as well as anti-Asian politics,
but rhetorically they're often
framed as anti-communists,
and in some ways deserving of US aid.
But this was not the way
it was seen in Malaysia.
I think that Malaysia plays
a really complicated role.
On the one hand it offers
refuge to thousands,
tens of thousands of Vietnamese,
and yet on the other hand,
they begin casting people off to sea,
pushing boats away, off to Indonesia,
which results in thousands
of people drowning,
and ends up having a very harsh policy
towards these Vietnamese boats.
And so there's a real
conflicted relationship.
On this island, Pulau Bidong,
the conditions are quite
difficult and complicated.
I had the good fortune of being
able to go to Pulau Bidong
about a year ago.
This is today.
These are the archival
images from the 1970s.
(speaker mumbling)
Oh yes.
Thank you.
Thank you for putting up Quan's article.
It's fantastic.
And here we have,
again, images from Pulau Bidong.
But one of the things
that I want to talk about
is how did Malaysia see
these Vietnamese differently
than the United States?
One thing that is notable
is that a disproportionate
number of these Vietnamese
were Chinese Vietnamese.
This is notable because in Malaysia
this meant that they were seen differently
than they were either in Hong
Kong or in the United States.
This is because Malaysia has a population,
which is about 40% Malay,
about 20 to 30% Chinese ethnicity,
and about 10 to 50% South Asian.
What this means is that
there is a way in which in Malaysia,
these incoming Vietnamese
were seen as "Chinese."
It meant that in Malaysia,
there was anxiety
about them actually
bringing communism with them
to Malaysia.
From the United States point of view,
this would seem counter-intuitive.
These are individuals who are
fleeing a communist country.
These are individuals
who generally narrate their experiences
as being anti-communist.
Yet the Malay newspapers, the Malay texts,
often their xenophobia took
a lens of anti-Chineseness,
and also anti-communism.
So if we think today about
the ways in the United States,
for example,
anti-Syrian refugee politics
can often come into this idea
of seeing Syrians as terrorists,
even though the Syrians
are fleeing terrorist acts,
here we see something similar
where we see Chinese
Vietnamese somehow being blamed
or associated with the very government
that they are trying to leave.
I just wanna give you a few examples.
So for example, in Mastika,
which was a Malay language newspaper
that was very popular
in Malaysia at the time,
that they would argue that
rather than seeing them
Malaysia's anti-communist haven,
it said that they suspected
that the communist agents
were gonna go and make contacts
with the Malaysian Communist Party.
The New Strait Times explicitly said
that this was essentially their fear.
The Far Eastern Economic Review
reported that the government feared Hanoi
was intentionally "planting agents"
among the so-called refugees.
There was a letter to the editor
in the Far Eastern
Economic Review that said,
"The communist underground
in Peninsular Malaysia
"led by Chin Peng was and still
is dominated by the Chinese.
"The idea that Chinese are communist
"is embodied in the minds of the Malays.
"They form an equation.
"Chinese equals communists,
"Chinese equals refugees.
"Therefore refugees equals communists."
And the government argued
for constant vigilance
and it even suggested that many of those
"who were running away' had
supported the Viet Cong."
So there was this, I would
say, real ambilevous.
On the one hand, I actually
want to recognize that Malaysia
took in tens of thousands of people.
And then a moment when we see
countries around the globe,
including in terms of its
particularly the United States,
refusing refugees,
Malaysia actually did
face a fair deal of burden
taking in large numbers of people.
On the other hand,
there was a great deal of xenophobia,
which I think we see in
almost any nation state.
In addition,
this sort of rhetoric of
fear about the Vietnamese
as infiltrating Malaysia,
that's why they had to be kept
on Pulau Bidong, an island,
we don't wanna let them
associate with Malaysians.
This will lead to in many ways,
Malaysia's much harsher policy
where they begin instituting,
which is pushing these boats off to sea.
This results in people both dying,
and great deals of trauma
and will lead to Mahathir's comments.
Prime Minister, Mohamad Mahathir
becomes one of the most
important Malaysian politician
of the 20th century and into the 21st.
He is still the Deputy Prime
Minister at this point.
And he says in 1979,
"Our patience is fully extended.
"If 500,000 immigrants
try to land in Britain,
"they might probably shoot them.
"We've already been accused by Newsweek
"of shooting any illegal immigrants.
"So we might as well do it
and justify their accusations.
"We are tired of being nice and humane
"and what did we get, nothing.
"So why bother?
Mohathir's frustration broke all polite
or diplomatic pretenses,
and the "New York Times" reported
that shoot on site legislation
could be forthcoming.
His strong word succeeded
in capturing international intention,
gaining sort of momentum,
and forcing along with Hong
Kong and Great Britain,
the UNHCR to come up with a new formula
that would grant Vietnamese
rights to first asylum.
I think this is interesting
because Malaysia as an
independent country,
which had been a colony,
is trying to both assert
its national sovereignty,
is trying to in some ways
throw the language of
humanitarianism back at the West,
and is trying to negotiate
essentially how to maintain
control over its borders.
Even as the boarder is providing support
and the Red Crescent Society
provides a great deal of support
for the Vietnamese in the camps,
as well as in many ways
going alongside the Malay chauvinism,
that is very much apparent
in the Malaysian politics.
This will result in the 1979
UNHCR Conference in Geneva.
And this will create a framework
which will provide refugee status
and first asylum status for Vietnamese
who land in first asylum
countries from 1979 to 1989.
So essentially it's a
three part agreement.
First, Vietnam will start
preventing Vietnamese
from leaving so easily.
And it will also start
what's called The Orderly
Departure Program,
which will allow Vietnamese
to leave from Vietnam.
That program doesn't really get going
through the late '80s,
but it gets started in 1980, '79-1980.
and it's actually,
I think one of the
missing things in my book.
I think there's a great book
to be written about the ODP
and hopefully someone in this
group might be doing that.
Secondly, it said the
first asylum countries
will accept Vietnamese.
They will not push them off.
This doesn't mean it totally stops,
it does keep happening,
but at least in principle
there will be first asylum.
Secondly, it says that the United States,
Europe, resettlement countries,
will accept everyone who
shows up in the camps.
They will all get resettled
in a third country.
That's the 1979 agreement.
Finally, at this point,
the last thing I wanna add
before turning to Hong Kong,
is we begin to get Vietnamese activism.
Oh goodness, here we go.
We began to get Vietnamese activism.
I liked this image here.
This is a group of Vietnamese Americans
advocating for support
of this 1979 Agreement.
And you began to have
organizations like IRAC,
which was the Inner China
Research Action Committee
lobbying the UN.
You begin to have groups
like Boat People SOS,
becoming active in refugee politics,
and recognizing
that if they wanted to be
able to protect Vietnamese
who want to leave the country,
that they would be able...
they needed to start
sort of finding power.
That was both through the United Nations
and through the United States.
These groups, both IRAC,
and Boat People SOS
began lobbying both the
UN and US politicians.
We see this emerging in the late 1970s.
This is just an image from, again,
my most recent trip,
and again, Quan has written
much more about this.
I found this a really moving
memorial on Pulau Bidong.
Someone has been reciting
inside of a solar powered
musical apparatus.
When you go through this memorial,
you actually hear music
even though it is generally unpopulated.
Last point before we turn
to questions, Hong Kong.
Key points about Malaysia.
Malaysian sovereignty,
specificities of Malaysian politics,
beginnings of diasporic activism.
Hong Kong.
So this is a map, I think Carina,
this might even be one of the maps
that you and I both use.
This is one of the maps
of the various camps
within Hong Kong.
I'm gonna actually,
this is from the artwork from UC Irvine,
and this is also
from the University of
California Irvine, archive.
I'll show you the images at the end.
So why Hong Kong?
Hong Kong becomes a key
site in the late 1980s.
I think that we see here why
the politics of place matter.
Hong Kong is a British colony.
It was North of Vietnam.
So you've got a larger number of people
from Northern Vietnam coming to Hong Kong.
This will make a big
difference to how refugees
or the Vietnamese are seen in Hong Kong,
because they are coming
from Northern Vietnam.
But Hong Kong is British.
British colonialism,
they're supposed to be humanitarian.
There's a lot of pressure on Hong Kong,
and they are very proud that
they do not push boats off
the way the Malaysians did,
but they do put the Vietnamese in camps.
But from 1979 to 1988,
Hong Kong accepts all
of the Vietnamese coming
and all the Vietnamese
who show up in Hong Kong,
get refugee status.
And again, a lot of this,
and Carina has done work on this as well,
and you might wanna add in later Carina
when we have a conversation.
We have large numbers coming to Hong Kong.
What happens though is
that Hong Kong's politics
are against specific.
Two things more than two,
but two I wanna mention
make Hong Kong really different.
One, if you are Chinese
and you wanna come to Hong Kong in 1985,
you're deported.
You're sent back.
So if you are a Hong Kong Chinese person
and your cousin comes over from Shanghai,
unllegally undocumented,
you got sent back.
That meant a lot of people
in Hong Kong were like,
"Wait a second,
"why do the Vietnamese get to stay?
"Why did they get resettled?
"If my spouse from China
doesn't get to, why not?
"Why did these Vietnamese
get this special treatment?"
Secondly, Hong Kong is going
to be come China in 1997.
There's this pressure on Hong Kong,
to navigate this transition
from the British to Chinese sovereignty.
Hong Kong doesn't have a
lot of independent power.
What I argue is that
by changing the policy,
vis-a-vis the Vietnamese,
it is a way for Hong Kong politicians
to reassert their own agenda,
at a moment where they
don't have a lot of control.
And so that really shapes
what will become the
fate of these Vietnamese
in the late 1980s.
So what happens?
A lot happens.
In 1988, Hong Kong basically
rips up the UNHCR Accord.
They say, "Too many people are coming,"
and really importantly,
and this brings in the United States,
"United States is not
resettling these people."
United States says, "These
people are from North Vietnam,
"they're not South Vietnamese,
"they're not really refugees,
"and so they're not our problem."
The British don't take them.
The British say, "We've
taken 10,000 people,
"not our problem."
And so Hong Kong is saying,
"Well, what are we going to do then?"
And so you should know
that the United States
in many ways passes the buck,
in a way and avoids responsibility.
And so Hong Kong,
the politicians say, "Then fine.
"Then we're gonna change.
"We can't take this anymore.
"We need to change this policy
"otherwise people are gonna
be in camps for years,
"and we're gonna have China
here in the next 10 years.
"We need to change.
"And the change is this.
"You'll no longer
automatically be a refugee.
"Instead, you will become an asylum seeker
"and we will interview you.
"And you can prove to us that
you really are a refugee,
"then yes, you can be
resettled in the United States
"or Canada or Australia.
"But if you cannot prove that,
"if we think you are simply poor
"or we think your story's too confusing,
"or we think that you weren't prosecuted
"or persecuted enough,
"then you will be repatriated
"and we will send you back to Vietnam."
At first, the United Nations
is really opposed to this.
They say, "No, that's wrong.
"We can't be doing that.
"We can't be sending people back."
But under Sergio Vieira,
which is actually really interesting,
Sergio Vieira de Mello.
He becomes an important
person in the United Nations.
He actually dies tragically in Iraq.
They say,
"Actually, we think this is a good idea."
The UN turns around and says,
"We are going to embrace this new model."
They come up with dates.
They're different in Hong Kong
than they are in the other
Southeast Asian countries.
But after these cutoff dates,
you will no longer be a refugee.
You will have to make your case,
and if you can't, you will
be sent back to Vietnam.
This leads to massive,
both legal and political
protests in the camps
in Hong Kong.
This also happens in Malaysia as well,
but I focus my research on Hong Kong.
There's a way in which I argue here,
that there is a clash between
where the Hong Kong government
liked to see as its humanitarian policies
and credentials of safe harbor,
and what Vietnamese American activists
argued was a violation
of their human rights.
You can see here really a
contrast between these two.
This will lead to a great deal of activism
within the camps,
I'm gonna share my screen here again.
This will lead to both political activism.
You'll get lots of protests like this one,
and for me also,
this image versus the one
in Guam are really striking.
Sort of similar protests,
but for different ends.
These Vietnamese are protesting
both against the screening,
many thought the screening
itself was wrong.
They believed themselves to be refugees.
And secondly, against repatriation.
They do not wanna be sent back to Vietnam.
These are images largely
from the English language
Hong Kong newspapers.
We are victims of the Hong Kong screening.
Here again,
we see the Hong Kong security
forces entering these camps.
This leads to very violent
showdowns within the camps.
This is in the late '90s
in the Whitehead detention centres.
These will become massive demonstrations
where again Vietnamese will protest,
often very physically with their bodies,
through hunger strikes,
through self-mutilation, through attacks,
arguing that they themselves are refugees
and do not wanna go back.
Artistic representation,
here are forced deportations
or repatriations.
In addition, these are
really traumatic images,
and there was even more of this.
This archive is vast.
Again, Carina's done a great job,
both of documenting those stories
and of showing both images and video.
In addition, alongside this,
we get a lot of activism
from dye-spot Vietnamese Americans
and Vietnamese Australians.
So you begin to have groups, for example,
UC Irvine is a large centre
of Vietnamese American community,
project NOC, as well as other groups
begin to send volunteers
to work with Vietnamese in Hong Kong.
They provide English
classes and art classes.
You also get lawyers.
So you begin to have
Americans send lawyers
to Hong Kong to help
advocate for the Vietnamese
within the camps.
They are fairly successful,
but not in a grand way.
Right?
So they have individual cases,
but they don't get the policy changed.
You also get groups like Boat People SOS
that's transformed from groups
that actually saved people at sea
to a really strong lobbying organization
in Northern Virginia,
that is able to get bipartisan support,
but really a lot of support
from the Republican Congress members
to try to again, prevent repatriations
or to provide more avenues for Vietnamese
to be resettled in the United States.
I'm interested in the dye-spot activism
and the networks between
the activism in the camps,
as well as within the United
States and in Australia.
And so what happens in the end?
In the end, about 60,000 people
from Hong Kong are deported,
about 30,000 more people
from other camps throughout Southeast Asia
are also repatriated.
The numbers are really large.
Almost 100,000 people are
in the end repatriated.
I think the story's
really important though,
for the same reasons.
One place matters.
It mattered that you had
all Chinese majority.
It mattered that Hong
Kong was a British colony.
It matters that 1997,
it was looming for these
Hong Kong politicians.
The part of Hong Kong are radical...
they're not worried about the
Vietnamese being communists,
like the Malaysians were.
Rather, they have their
own set of concerns
and that shaped their policies.
Secondly, they're against the activism.
The Vietnamese were extremely organized,
extremely strategic
in how they were creating both
legal and political campaigns
to prevent repatriation
and also creating strategic alliances
with Vietnamese already in the West.
Okay.
So those are in some ways the main points.
Where to end?
I just wanna add that
these are obviously stories
that still matter today.
I just wanna end with a few last images.
There are stories just from two years ago,
many in this Zoom Room are
probably familiar with these.
But the Trump administration
began deporting Vietnamese
who came in the 80s and 90s.
Many of them came and
(indistinct) with the law,
we're not able to become US citizens
and have been proactively deporting
very vulnerable population
that had often been in the United States
for 10, 15, 20 years.
This has again led
to Vietnamese diasporic activism.
This was from about two years ago.
Here my politics, I like this one,
Forget Trump,
from a recent Vietnamese American
protest against these deportations.
I think that with the
United States in many ways,
using Mexico as a place to
keep refugees right now,
we see the ways in which wealthy countries
have acted to keep people
outside of their borders.
I think that we need to
be a much more attention
to places like Mexico and Turkey,
that had been holding these
large numbers of refugees,
as we understand refugee politics today.
So I've gone a little bit over,
but we have about 15, 20 minutes.
I hope people found that interesting.
I would, love to hear
your questions or comments
or arguments or critiques.
- Thank you, Jana.
Take a moment (clapping) and applaud
this wonderful presentation.
I will take on the role of moderator,
so that we'll allow Jana to
pay attention to the speakers
and the questions that are asked.
So what I propose is that
if you have a question,
you use the hand-raising function on Zoom.
You can go down in the participant section
and raise your hand and I'll
try to keep track of you.
If for some reason you're having trouble
with the hand-raising function
and you can't get my attention,
you realize that I haven't seen you,
just please send a chat to
the everyone part of the chat,
say that you have a question
or you can even post the question
and then we'll allow Jana
to read it and answer.
So lemme start by calling on anyone.
Does anyone wanna start off our Q & A?
Also please keep your
questions relatively short
so that we can allow as
many people as possible,
to ask questions.
I should also add that
the event officially ends
at one o'clock, but I'll stick around,
I'll keep the Zoom window
open for another 15 minutes
after that if you have extra questions.
Who would like to start?
(door banging)
We'll start with Quan.
- Hi Jana.
Thank you so much for your amazing talk
and congratulations on the book.
I was very struck...
so I just a book over the summer
and I thought the temporal
coverage of the book,
was really expansive
and it really takes our
understanding of refugees
beyond ascending and host
country relationship.
And so I really think the
conversation about thinking
about refugee camps as sites
that are often transit,
but here you're centreing these sites.
So I'm wondering,
if you could say a little bit more about,
thinking of camp as an analytic,
and how might, these
forgotten or abandoned sites,
help us re-centre
interstate relationships?
- Now, that is a wonderful question.
And thank you so much
and thank you for your work as well.
I just wanna tell you how
much I enjoy your work.
I guess for me, and this in
some ways it brings me back.
There's a way in which my work might seem
to not make sense.
I wrote a book about Cuba,
and now I'm bouncing
over to Southeast Asia.
And so what am I doing?
But the link actually is
the analytic of camps.
Because if you think about the ways,
and this is how I'm thinking,
about the ways in which
I write about Guantanamo,
and I write about the Naval
base in Guantanamo Bay.
And I'm trying to think about
how do spaces that seem
peripheral and marginal
actually become central
to imperial politics.
I think that Empire's used places
that seem to be out of the way,
but in fact, magnify both
the extent of their power
and the limits, right?
And so I like playing with those tensions.
I think that there's a
way in which militaries
very clearly understand this.
We think about where
military bases are located,
they understand the value of both being
on the periphery of places
that might be missed,
but yet seems still important.
I'm thinking about like
bases like Diego Garcia
and the Indian ocean,
or if we think about
where, their point of camp.
So I think that there's a way
in which thinking more
about networks of power
and the relationship between
empires and local communities,
that camps become places
where those tensions become visible.
Where we can see the ways
in which governments both
try to have state control,
and then also in some ways
the limits of those control
in a place like the camp.
I hope that helps answer your question,
but that's where I see my Guantanamo work
really in some ways
reverberating analytically,
even if it's not there in the archives.
- Thanks for the great answer.
Next question will be from
Nu-Anh Tran at the
University of Connecticut.
- Hi, thank you for the presentation.
That was really interesting.
My question is about
how the politics of the refugees differ,
due to the composition of the refugees.
You talked about how there are
more Northerners in Hong Kong
versus more Southerners in
some of the other camps.
I was also thinking
that in the later years,
there are more people
who are actually just there
for like a short period of time
who are trying to think who was ODP
and not actually boat people.
The other reason why I'm asking this is
because I noticed that in
the picture from Hong Kong,
there are people using the RVN flag,
the South Vietnamese flag.
So I was just wondering if like
the symbols or the arguments
or the tensions within
the refugee politics
differ by location
because of the composition
of the camp population.
- You know it's really good question
and I don't think my answer is as good.
In some ways the South Vietnamese
flag is used repeatedly
because I think it's a legible symbol.
And so for the people protesting,
they want to be seen as refugees,
and so the South Vietnamese
flag is valuable in that way.
I'm not trying to underestimate
their actual affinity with the flag.
My guess is most of
the time it was strong.
But it's a useful symbol.
What I think is notable,
and again, I'm looking
over to Carina on the side,
but there's a lot of tension
between the North Vietnamese
and the South Vietnamese.
Actually I think this is
an area for more research
and this is where the fact
that I don't speak Vietnamese,
I'll be really clear.
I am not a Vietnamese language
speaker or reader matters,
and where I think someone
who does know Vietnamese
could do more work.
A lot of time that there's anger
and there's physical fighting
between the North Vietnamese
and South Vietnamese
in the Hong Kong camps,
this is often attributed
to, regional tensions.
I think what I think my hunch and again,
maybe some of the
Vietnamese could do more,
I think that's true.
I also think though that it is true
that the North Vietnamese resented
that the South Vietnamese
were seen as refugees.
That it was easier if
you were South Vietnamese
to get refugee status.
So there were both
maybe lingering tensions
vis-a-vis the actual
conflicts between North
and South Vietnam,
but there was also I think,
anger about who was seen as a refugee.
The other one I would only add is that,
and I think, John Christianson Knutson
has written a great deal about this
and this idea of the screening machine
as Yen Leah Speartoov.
But there was a need to
tell a certain story,
like in any refugee context.
The right story was,
"My father was in the
South Vietnamese Military,
"I was discriminated against
"because I was from South Vietnam.
"My father was in a re-education camp."
That story was a story
that people would tell
because it was effective.
What that does is it
minimized other stories.
So just quickly,
one story that I really found emotive
or compelling with one that didn't fit.
Which was a story of
a North Vietnamese man
who went to East Germany
on a work program.
When he was there, he got involved with
independent union politics.
So he gets deported from East Germany
and sent back to North Vietnam.
Then he gets in problems there.
So they send him to Hong Kong.
He actually fit the definition
of an anti-communist refugee.
But because he'd been to East Germany
and was from Northern Vietnam
and was a union activist,
it didn't look right.
I think the symbols are
being used strategically
as well sometimes,
although not to underestimate
people's actual affinities either.
Carina wants to jump in for a second.
- Is it okay for me to say something now?
- Yeah.
Trinh, do you mind letting
Carina jump in real quick?
Go ahead.
- Thank you Trinh.
- Just wanna add into this
particular conversation
about North Vietnamese and
South Vietnamese in the camp.
I was in the refugee camp in Indonesia,
and we didn't have this problem
with Vietnamese fighting among each other
as much as Hong Kong.
When you were talking
about the North Vietnamese
being resentful to a South Vietnamese,
because they will not
consider as refugees,
and interestingly South
Vietnamese in the camp
also resent the fact that
because of the North,
they think because of the North Vietnamese
that put them at risk of
getting refugee status.
Also the South Vietnamese who were stuck
in the camp in Hong Kong,
blaming the North communist,
because of you guys,
now I lost country, I got to
escape and now I'm stuck here,
so that's all they have.
That political tension between them
and of course different cultures,
different values
and the lifestyle North
Vietnamese and South Vietnamese
are so different.
Because of the fights
that they constantly have,
it's actually put the Vietnamese refugees
in a disadvantage situation,
because the Hong Kong
residents were saying that,
we host you here, we provide you safety,
we give everything to you,
but you burned down the camp,
you are causing problems.
So eventually the Hong Kong residencies,
they protest more toward the government
and said, "Do not accept any
more Vietnamese refugees."
So that's another layer of pressure
that the Hong Kong
government had to deal with.
- Great.
Thank you Carina.
- Trinh.
- Thank you so much for
your wonderful book talk
Professor Lipmann.
I am thinking a lot about
what you said about Mexico,
and I'm also thinking too,
like the camps in Europe,
like for example, Moria
which just burnt down
to two weeks ago.
It never really occurred
to me to think of camps
in like Wan in Hong Kong as
sites of like liminality,
but also agency.
But the thing is the
reception of refugees,
like Vietnamese refugees in Southeast Asia
and "cold war" refugees
was quite different
than what's going on today.
I know that's just one facet of it.
So, thinking to your work
across countries like in Cuba,
how do you understand the
difference in response
to efforts to self advocate
for resettlement and such?
- I think that's exactly right.
I don't wanna be nostalgic
for the cold war.
But on the other hand,
the cold war put pressure
on places like the United
States and Great Britain
to accept people
in a way that our current government
does not feel external pressure to do so.
I think that we are dealing with,
far more fraught situations in some ways
than Cubans or Vietnamese
did in the 70s, 80s and 90s.
I think when I was doing my research...
and very critical of the
Hong Kong government,
in the book in multiple ways,
although I also am somewhat sympathetic
to the pressures that they faced,
and there's a way in which
they keep being worried
that if they push people off,
people won't think of them
as being humanitarian.
They're supposed to be British.
They can't do X
because they have to be
seen as humanitarian.
I was like, "Oh my goodness.
"If only our countries still
felt pressure to look good,
"things would be at least
a little bit better."
And that sort of need
to at least have a facade
of humanitarianism,
even that is gone as gone.
I think that that eraser
or political stance
that we don't even need to pretend
to be protecting human rights anymore,
is a huge shift from the cold
war the post cold war age.
That a country like the United States,
and arguably even
countries in Western Europe
no longer even have to pretend
that they care about human
rights and humanitarianism.
In a way that some of the pressures,
both of colonialism on England,
as well as the United
States where the cold war
created at least a need
to pay a little bit more than lip service.
That is no longer even the case.
I think the situation
right now is really grim.
I think the Vietnamese...
and many of them were sent back.
I'm not again trying
to underestimate that.
But today people have even fewer avenues
because the legal system
has been so monopolized
by conservative administrative judges.
- It's time for a question from Peter.
(door banging)
Professor Lipmann, I have a question
in regards to the Malaysian case example.
At the time, were there
local Chinese Malay,
political parties, organizations, bodies,
whatsoever and what have you,
who advocated for these "Chinese"
coming into the country or did they say,
"Oh, no, we don't want
anything to do with them?"
- So that's a really good question.
I tried to do some research on that
and I found less than
I would have thought.
But even that silence
I think is interesting.
I would again say that's an area
where I think there
should be more research.
And again, with someone
whose language skills
are better than mine.
I was in Malaysia for several weeks,
I had a research translator
who could speak both Chinese and Malay.
So we looked at a lot
of Chinese newspapers
and Chinese Malaysian newspapers
to see what were the Chinese
political parties saying.
Right?
'Cause there are several
Chinese political parties
in Malaysia,
some that were affiliated
with the government
and some of them were in the opposition.
There was actually remarkably little
in the Chinese language
newspapers at the time.
In fact, the Malay newspapers commented
on the Chinese language
newspapers' silence.
It seems to be that there was a reluctance
to support the Chinese Vietnamese
because it would have been
politically unpopular.
They were in some ways concerned
about not being seen
as nationalists enough.
Right.
They wanna be seen as being
Malaysian nationalists
and not specific towards
the Chinese Vietnamese.
There are leaders who do
talk about humanitarianism.
They are often against
the government's desire
to push people off.
But I would say there was actually much...
I thought there was gonna be a lot more
in the Chinese language
newspapers in Malaysia,
in fact, there was a lot more
in the Malay language newspapers,
than there was in the Chinese.
I would only add,
and this is where someone
like Carina's working.
There are other oral history collections.
What I did find instead though,
was in Vietnamese oral histories,
people would say, "Oh,
a Chinese Malaysian,
"met me on the shore and helped me out."
Or, "Oh, so-and-so met me
"and they helped me get
to the right place."
There seemed to be at a personal level,
some connections and
they often both spoke,
sometimes it's shared to Chinese language,
sometimes it not.
Malaysians speak,
generally speak a
different Chinese dialect
and then Cantonese.
But in any case,
there were some moments where
there in the oral histories,
these moments of connection
would come together.
But I found that the
Chinese language press
was much quieter on this
topic than I had anticipated.
- We'll turn to Tiffany.
Tiffany you need to unmute
briefly you're still muted.
- Alright.
Well I was saying that
thanks so much to Jana
for putting together such a wonderful book
that provides invaluable resources
for those of us who want to learn
about this exodus history.
I came across at the UNHCR archives.
I came across a number of documents
talking about people in
1975 wanted to repatriate,
but I never really followed up on that.
But it's so wonderful and really exciting
to actually read your book
and learn about that in more detail.
I also appreciate
the way you navigate the
sensitivity of terminology,
especially whether to call
all Vietnamese refugees
as a lot of humanitarian
groups would advocate for.
For me it just the sake of
identifying different periods
and how policy changes in
Southeast Asia, in Hong Kong
and with the UNHCR as well,
that we have to make that clear.
I really liked the way you navigated that.
Now my question is,
in terms of the title, "In Camps,"
I understand that in Vietnamese language,
they call everything 'Trai' means 'camp.'
but with the case of Hong Kong,
I was with a group of Vietnamese
that got resettled in
Hong Kong for three years,
and I listened to the
way they used the terms,
and it has always been very separate.
Because there were a
number of detention centres
that hosted Vietnamese refugees.
This is including Victoria prison
that turned into Tai Kwun contemporary art
that I worked at like few years ago.
Most of them call 'giam tam',
to refer to detention centre
and 'trai ti nan' to refugee camp.
'Giam tam' also, I think
the term came about in 1982,
when Hong Kong started to
enforce close camp policy,
even admitting Vietnamese as refugees,
there was still like close camp policies,
so the Vietnamese would not be able
to move around freely.
So how did you navigate around
this kind of like limelight
to come up with a title In Camp?
- That's a really good question
and in some ways I think
is also a really valuable critique.
I guess I would say a few things.
One is that you are,
first of all, correct.
They're not all camps,
they don't have barbed wire...
In Pulau there's no barbed wire,
even a lot of the times.
By then the Philippines,
these are open places where
people would work outside
and it was very different.
I think that I chose
the title in some ways,
because I wanted to be
raising the questions
that Quan asked earlier
about the idea of the camp.
Thinking about these spaces where people
were before resettlement
and after they left.
And so I think that you're right.
That in some ways it may be
too simplistic or catchy,
but in surveys lines,
these are larger linguistic
and political ideas.
But the reason I guess I landed on it
because it was able to bring together
all the multiple stories
that I was trying to tell
from Guam to Malaysia,
to Hong Kong, to the Philippines.
And even if it is not as precise a term
as potentially, it should be,
it allowed me to make the
argument and the title
that the book is about
why we must think about
these places in between
and why that is necessary
for actually understanding
refugee politics.
So I take your points really seriously,
but I guess from my point of view,
it did some of the analytical work
that I wanted it to do by
bringing the stories together.
- I think there's a good,
like all encompassing kind of term,
like when you use the word camp,
because that when you can also critique
these refugee places
are actually military bases and camps.
So I do see the point.
Thank you.
- Yeah, no, thank you.
- Great question.
I wanna flag to everyone
that it's one o'clock
for those of you who had appointments
and needed to leave,
but we'll go into extra time,
as if it's a exciting soccer match.
So we'll go into extra time now,
and I have a question from Ivan Small.
So Ivan.
- Thanks Jana for really
a interesting talk
and for an interesting book.
I've picked it up and started reading it.
I just had a quick question.
I was curious.
Are there many people in
the Vietnamese diaspora
that are interested in
returning to these camps?
And, using this camp as a
site of collective memory?
You mentioned, help and Pulau
and there was kind of an
effort there under Father Vien,
but it seemed like that didn't work out.
So I was wondering if
there are concerted efforts
right now to do that.
- This is where Quan
has done much more work
than I have.
But no, there not to live by any stretch
of the imagination.
But as far as pilgrimage sites,
there are large numbers,
or I don't know what,
they're sizeable numbers
of Vietnamese in diaspora,
United States, Canada, Australia,
who have gone back to these
places as pilgrimage sites.
And Carina has also brought people
to the camps in former sites in Indonesia.
There's a way in which...
so for example, when I was in Malaysia
they're temples,
there's statues that are maintained
by diasporic groups,
the man who took me to Pulau Bidong,
takes Vietnamese Australian
groups regularly.
Many people died in these camps
and in some ways these camps are places,
where people lost people.
But there is,
I think a sense of return,
there's large numbers of religious
memorials in these camps.
I think that there's not any
interest in resettlement,
like Father Vien was about
bringing Vietnamese Americans
to help out at the camps, right.
To bringing volunteers.
And then you have this, vision.
This is in the Philippines,
there was an idea that Philippines
does not deport people.
That Philippines, resettles
a group of Vietnamese
in the Philippines.
In the end that group
doesn't actually wanna
stay in the Philippines,
most of them also want to
come to the United States
and eventually do as late as 2005.
But Vietnamese Americans
more, have gone...
I would think the word pilgrimage
is probably appropriate,
but if Quan or Carina
want to have a different nuance on it,
be interested in your thoughts.
But not as far as resettling,
but as far as they are trips.
Does that answer your question, Ivan?
- Yeah, thank you.
- Okay.
I don't know if Carina wanna add anything.
- Thanks Jana.
Can I add to that?
It's just also,
in terms of what became
of these camps after
resettlement or repatriation.
In the cases of Indonesia
and Malaysia, for example,
some of those camps or
remnants of those camps
continue to be there,
and they've actually turned into like
tourist destinations
for not just the refugees
who are returning
to visit as pilgrimage sites,
but also for local populations
and the kind of laws that are associated
now with these forlorn
places in some ways.
In the case of Hong Kong,
or even in Thailand,
the traces of those camps
are no longer physically visible.
You really have to dig for it.
There's no concerted effort
to preserve these sites, on a local level.
That also impact the ability of people
to go back and think about
on individual levels.
So there are people who
do go back as individuals,
there are organizations in the diaspora,
that are kind of spearheading
some of these pilgrimage tours
and so on.
- Carina, please join in.
- Yes.
In terms of Indonesia,
sort of unique than the
other places, in two ways.
The main refugee camp in phosphoric,
became a tourist attraction place,
mainly for Vietnamese who return to visit.
But for places where I
would like Co To Island,
where I first landed, these
were uninhabited islands.
So initially there were
hundreds of Vietnamese refugees
died as soon as we arrived
in the first few months,
so more and more Vietnamese people
return to these places,
to look for the graves
of their loved ones.
A lot of my work for refugees
focus on these in uninhabited islands,
just mainly looking
for graves of refugees.
- I would also add to Quan's point
in the Philippines it's very different.
Maybe not that different,
but the main camp in the
Philippines was in Bataan,
which is the Philippine
Refugee Processing Center.
That is not part of my talk.
It was very different.
The Philippines Refugee Processing Center
was for people who had already
been given a refugee status.
The United States said,
"Well, before you come to America,
"it will be cheaper for
you to learn English
"in the Philippines for six months,
"and then you'll come
to the United States."
And so people there
knew they were gonna get
to the United States or Germany,
or Norway, is a few people.
But that now is a museum.
It's somewhat different
because the Philippine government
is very proud of that project.
Some of it actually is also fallen down
because they don't have
the hundreds of thousands
of people there anymore,
but there's also a museum there.
Avenna Speartov
who also does a lot of this work
has done a film about the PRPC camp.
- If there's no objection,
I'd like to ask a question too.
I just wanted to add before
asking my own question,
the article I mentioned
that Quan had written
also adds to your story
about the politics within Southeast Asia
that takes place during the refugee,
but also the politics of memorialization.
There's some pretty dramatic stories
that Quan relays in that about,
the Vietnamese government,
interacting with Asian and
some of the various countries
in order to remove memorials,
and the kind of political
pressures that are going
on there as well,
which is quite fascinating.
So the story you tell is quite...
it lingers into the post-exodus period.
I wanna ask a question,
that's kind of a little bit about
how you wrote the book.
I'll preface it a little bit
for those who haven't read it yet.
But as you heard from the talk everyone,
the book is organized
sort of by geographically,
but at the same time...
so we have the different places.
We have Malaysia,
we have Guam,
Starts with Guam, then there's Malaysia,
then there's the
Philippines and Hong Kong.
It gives this wonderful geographic spread
of the inter-Asian politics
and the different politics
of the different places.
But at the same time,
this is my question.
At the same time, Jana,
you layer kind of a
historical chronology on top.
So it both goes kind of geographically,
but also goes historically.
So we start in Guam is for '75.
Malaysia is '75 through '79,
and that ends up in the
UNHCR conference in '79
that's very important.
There's the Bataan
which over-intersects with people power
in the Marcos regime and
Aquino and all this stuff.
And then there's, 1980
through '89 in Hong Kong,
which tells a different
kind of political story,
which ends up with this shift
that leads to screening.
So my question for you as a writer,
and as a historian,
how did you make that decision?
Because the camps don't necessarily stop
at the end of the period that you choose.
I was just curious,
what were some of your other options
for structuring the book
as you were imagining it,
and how you settled on this
and maybe some of the
challenges that you faced
as you made that choice?
- Thank you so much.
Thanks so much for reading it so closely.
It's a sprawling book.
You're right.
There's a way in which I stopped worrying
about Malaysia in 1979,
but of course there are Vietnamese
in Malaysia till the mid 90s.
Right?
So it doesn't quite work that way.
I guess I decided that there were...
as soon as I wrote my first book,
somebody's like this.
That I like thinking both
thematically and chronologically.
I was trying to figure out,
which were the stories I wanted to tell.
And where was the points?
Where were the places where
those questions sort of emerged?
I guess archivally what I did
is I had found all this stuff...
lemme talk a little backwards.
I found all of the material about Guam.
I was like, "This is an amazing story.
"I'm gonna run with it."
And then after that,
I didn't really know what I was doing.
And I didn't know much
about Southeast Asia.
I didn't even know about
the 1989 conference
or '79 on conference,
but I went to Geneva.
Geneva, the UNHCR archives.
I was like, I'm gonna start here.
And I'm gonna start by
looking at the Geneva archives
and from there deciding
where I was going to go.
So other factics of my book,
I don't deal with Thailand,
which was actually
quite important as well,
but it's more complicated
'cause you had so many more
people from Cambodia and Laos.
But there's a way that I started
with the Geneva archives.
Those archives led me to that,
Oh Malaysia is what they're
worried about in the '70s.
Then Hong Kong is what
they're worried about
in the '80s and '90s.
And so in many ways,
I used that initial trip to Geneva
and the UNHCRs archives
to think about what is the map,
both geographically and chronologically.
In some ways you could argue
that going to Geneva first,
it's going to the capital
rather than going to the sort of,
as Quan was asking the provinces, right?
Instead of going then
starting with the camps,
then going inward,
I started with the capital archives
and went outward.
But that allowed me to start thinking
about the landscape of the book.
And, from there,
I just had to make decisions
about where and when,
and I just decided
that I didn't have to tell the
whole story about Malaysia.
That it was gonna be okay.
That the stories in Hong Kong
were more illustrative of
that moment of screening,
even though there was screening
in Malaysia or Indonesia.
- Great.
- I hope that answers your question.
- No it really does.
And I wanna just respond by saying it
wasn't a critique so much,
as I was actually thought it
was a very elegant solution
to telling both the chronological
and geographical story
that brought all the politics
of the different places,
but then sort of punctuates it
with the significance of a certain place.
I thought it was very interesting.
- Thank you.
- We're at 1:15 now.
We have one question from Francis Martin,
and if there's no objections,
I'll make that the last question.
But if anyone else,
wants to send
the question--
- I'll hang on a little bit.
- you can just send it to the...
Also if you have an important question
they can't squeeze in,
send it to the chat
so Jana has at her disposal
also just for her information.
Francis.
- Hi, Dr. Lipmann.
Thank you very much for your talk.
It was wonderful.
My question really,
again gets to the history
writing side of things.
How did language and
your limited access to,
again, language, Vietnamese,
Malay, Chinese, et cetera,
sort of narrow or limit the
stories you were able to tell?
- Yeah, absolutely.
So again, full disclosure
and I say this in the book.
I am an Anglophone.
I am an American my languages are minimal.
I actually really struggled with,
"Could I do this project
"as a English dominated language project?"
I talked to a lot of colleagues
and a lot of friends
and in a way,
and I hate to sound,
just it's hot spot,
it's like, I had tenure.
My first book was done.
I did learn Spanish for the first book.
I just was like,
I want to follow the stories
that I found in Guam.
I found that I'd done
other research in the US
that wasn't as compelling to me.
And I was like,
these are stories that
I felt I could follow.
Then I decided that I was not gonna
do an oral history project attached to it.
That there were other
people who knew Vietnamese
and could do those oral history projects,
with language 'cause that I don't have.
And so I draw on.
Carina's done a lot,
University of California Irvine
has a huge oral history collection.
Other people have been doing them.
I largely decided that I was not going try
to conduct a significant
oral history project.
I did some interviews.
I did some interviews in the project,
but I was gonna be cognizant
of my language limitations.
I also, in some ways
going to Erik's question
in terms of sites,
it should not be too hard to figure out
that I picked sites that were
British or American colonies.
That means you have a lot of
English language documents.
Between Guam, Malaysia, Hong
Kong, and the Philippines,
I would say the place
where the language was,
the biggest obstacle would be Malaysia.
More of the documents there
are in Malay and Chinese.
In a way that Hong Kong
clearly, if I knew Chinese,
I'd have access to a
whole another archive,
but there's plenty in English.
Similarly with the Philippines.
Most of the formal
documents in the Philippines
are in English.
Even though you have to go log newspapers,
it would have been useful
if I spoke Visayan,
at some point,
that it wasn't necessary
from an archival standpoint.
I also picked the sites
where I knew there would
be English sources.
But I think there's
plenty of work to be done
for people with language
skills better than mine.
I just decided that it was
the book I wanted to write
and that I was able to
find enough English sources
and then hire some translators
when I needed them.
So I hope that helps.
(keyboard clicking)
- Great.
Thanks Jana.
I think I'm gonna bring
this formally to close
and stop the recording.
But I want everyone (clapping) to join me
in thanking Jana for a wonderful talk.